what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and it seems like the perfect
time to try a new video series where I
break down the greatest moments of the
greatest characters in anime since we
always have requests for more esken or
videos and he's one of the most epic
characters in all of anime he seemed
like the perfect character to start with
if you liked the idea for this video and
want to see more like it definitely
smash that like button to let me know
and subscribe for future videos
also leave suggestions in the comments
with the names of your favorite anime
characters and I could make a similar
type of video for them there are plenty
of epic cool and/or simply great anime
characters out there so the
possibilities for this series are
endless and for these videos I'm gonna
try something new I often get people
asking for manga spoiler free videos and
I get just as many people saying they
want videos covering the manga so in an
attempt to satisfy everyone I'm going to
start with moments that take place in
the anime first and then I'll let you
know when I move into manga spoiler
territory later on in the video so no
matter where you are in the series you
can enjoy this video now without further
ado let's jump into it we might as well
go chronologically so we'll start with
Eska NORs first appearance in the manga
some of you might not know about this
because it wasn't animated but it's not
a spoiler it happens before the main
story and it was just a bonus manga so
it'll probably never get animated it's a
real shame that I won't get animated too
because there's plenty of
esken or epicness present within it
however we're esken or shines most
brilliantly is during his fight against
the vampire king Israel one of the many
reasons that s Kannur stands out so much
is because his daytime form is often
directly contrasted with his weak
nighttime form which serves to further
magnified a time ask Norse greatness
before the fight with a vampire king the
strongest of the vampires a 28 year old
feeblest Kannur is seen crying and
feeling sorry for ever being born
ESCA nor runs into the vampire king and
begins running away out of fear israel
comments that he drew the worst law of
the bunch
meaning the weakest fighter and
nor calls out for meliodas to save him
all Eskin or does before he begins his
transformation is cower and run in fear
this is why it seems all the more epic
when Eskin or suddenly calms down and
tells the big boss vampire king who has
a higher power level compared to all the
other sins at this point the following s
Connor says the Ezra apologized to me
that you were born into my world the
complete personality change the over
9000 level of pride is self-evident
he was crying freaking out and feeling
sorry for ever being born just a second
ago
and now he's calm confident and feels
like the whole world is his domain and
that he deserves an apology if people
are born into it without his consent
what makes this moment all the more epic
is that the vampire king has already
positioned eScan or as the weakest of
the seven deadly sins it is mine the
weak and cowering night-time Eskin or
made israel feel great about his
overwhelming power he thinks he's got
this fight in the bag and that
overconfidence makes Eskin ors
effortless triumph all the sweeter and
all the more epic is refuses his full
power against Eska nor he plays every
card he's got and it's all completely
useless esken or counters is rush
darkness without moving a muscle and not
only that he even pushes the vampire
King back in the process the pressure of
sunshine emanating from Eska Knorr body
alone overpowers the king of vampires
ESCA noir is not surprised or amused for
him it's clear that the darkness feared
him Israel says that the idea of a
king's darkness fearing a mere human is
laughable and esken or counters with
some of his most epic and prideful lines
in the entire series he says in this
realm kings such as yourself are as
numerous as grains of sand but I'm no
such thing I'm an existence unlike any
other in this world the lion sin of
pride Lord Eskin or Eskin or what is
rhetoric positions himself above kings
he claims that in his presence Kings
were supposed to be the highest-ranking
rulers in the world are nothing more
than grains of sand
they're as insignificant as dust thus
Eskin or positions himself as infinitely
superior to the rulers of entire clans
kingdoms and races they are even less
than ants to him and true to his word
ESCA nor goes on to defeat the vampire
king with a less effort then it would
take a human to kill an ant he simply
walks close to the king the power
emanating from him alone
turns the vampire king to ash Eskin or
simply moves his lips and boom the king
of the vampires dissolves into nothing
not only that Eskin or beat the
strongest opponent who was completely
assured of his victory he did it
effortlessly he completely stripped his
opponent of his pride he treated the
king of a proud and powerful race a race
that should be much stronger than the
human race mind you as less than an
annoying insect and that's just the
beginning of Eska Norse epic moments now
let's turn to s canora's anime
introduction where he fought against
gallant and molasse killer much like the
vampire king GLE and felt like he had
plenty of reasons to feel certain about
his victory previously Golan had almost
killed the sins go through had to trick
him into thinking he already had killed
them
to get him to leave then Bond had to use
all of his power just to run away from
Galland and Alaska gallons base power
level is 27,000 or 26,000 without magic
this is much higher than that of the
vampire king who had a power level up
4890 not only is this power level huge
and has pretty much allowed Galan to use
the sins as a punching bag up to this
point he even has an ace up his sleeve
he has his critical / mode which shoots
his power level up to a remarkable
40,000 this is why he decides to play a
game with the extremely weak looking
nighttime esken or because of Gallants
commandment of truth if either esken or
or Galan break their promise and abandon
the game they'll be turned to stone
ESCA nor so nervous he's sweating and
crying before he faints and falls down
at one point Galan notices the battle
axe Rita but he can't even pick it up in
his view it's flawed he thinks that the
handle should be three times longer so
it can be held with two hands it's so
heavy it has to be a two-handed axe but
daytime s Canora wakes and tells Galan
that Rita is in fact a one-handed axe
and effortlessly holds up the heavy axe
with one hand it is not long before the
man who
fainted in a sweaty and teary-eyed panic
a few pages ago proclaims that he stands
at the peak of all the races gallant and
mulaskey are laughing at us canard
arrogance before s Canora cuts off
Gallants head in an instant blasts close
shocked and the atmosphere has
completely changed --gel and is suddenly
starting to get serious his instincts
tell him that he has to go full out
against Eskin or so he puts all of his
power into his strongest slash remember
the game is meant for the players to
keep exchanging attacks until one is
dead ghal and just presented his most
overpowered form and put all his power
into this one deadly attack and yet it
is buddy paper cut to s kannur keep in
mind this isn't even s kannur at full
power his power is getting larger by the
minute as noon approaches Velasco
realizes how outmatched they are and
tells Golan that they need to retreat
but the proud gallant assures her that
he never goes against his word he will
finish the game and fight to the death
then when Eskin or Stern starts he winds
up for the swing Eskin are so powerful
that Galland strongest form looks like
an insect in his presence as esken or is
about to bring the ax down the land of
the truth gets so scared that he turns
and starts running away his old
commandant activates and turns him into
a stone now that is epic s Connor was so
powerful that he psychologically beat
Galan without even having to take a
serious swing ghal and was presented as
such a proud creature is utterly
disgraced by a mere human s Kannur being
the chivalrous man he is gives molasse
Killa the opportunity to run away if she
doesn't want to die however she tries to
eat his soul instead if s canora's
complete victory over the land wasn't
epic enough his soul ends up burning
molasse killa from the inside almost
killing her in the process literally
without trying
ESCA nor gets two of the legendary
commandments to pretty much defeat
themselves at this point it is clear
that s canora's on a whole other level
compared to any of the other sins his
battle against the monstrous
commandments was over before it even
began this is the magic of s Kannur he
defeats seemingly undefeatable opponent
and he makes it look effortless perhaps
the most epic battle in seven deadly
sins is Eskin oars battle against one of
the strongest commandments esta rosa
esther osa had previously killed Mellie
Otis although he came back because he
was cursed and stuff but still as serosa
was strong enough to do the impossible
he killed the main character of a
shounen series even if it was only
temporary he is presented as being equal
to if not stronger than Zell drous so
he's pretty much the strongest opponent
that Eskin or could face at this point
does this fact intimidate Eskin or not
in the least while most people can't
even move because of Esther OSes
commandment of love which makes all
people who feel hate in his presence
powerless ESCA nor is absolutely
unaffected in fact he tells us serosa
that he mustn't hate him for killing
DeLand a score is not only not scared of
Esther OSA he's worried that Esther OSA
might not be able to give him an
enjoyable fight if Esther OSA gives in
to his hate askin or quickly gets a
serosa to fall to his knees again in
epic Eskin or fashion Esther cannot even
acknowledge a serosa as a serious
opponent he asks him if he dropped a
coin or something
s ignores pretty much telling esta rosa
that he's not fighting seriously at all
askin or is implying that he held back
so much with his attack that there is no
way that Esther OSes heard after such a
weak hit thus the only logical
explanation is that he has to be looking
for coins or something ESCA nor is
utterly humiliating his opponent by
paradoxically overestimating his
opponents abilities then for the first
time s Kannur looks surprised by a wound
he received Esther OSA explains that he
has the ability full counter that takes
any physical attack made against them
and returns it many times over
then everything clicks for Eskin or he
says I see no wonder that hurts so badly
just as I expected from myself in his
view of course the only person that
could injure the man who stands at the
pinnacle of all races is himself
Esther OSA finally inflicts some real
damage on s Kannur and Eska nor manages
to turn it into a compliment that's the
beauty of Eskin or you cannot lower him
no one can one-up him he always appears
at the upper
and physically mentally and of course
rhetorically anyways Eskin or sunshine
ability being as Opie as it is
accidentally starts to burn the armor of
holy night star nearby while bond is
freaking out that everyone is going to
burn Eskin or calmly asks for directions
to a lake and then hits Estero saw all
the way to the lake and then drops a
cruel sun on him he evaporates the
entire lake in an instant
Esther also tries to act tough and turn
the tide of the fight he tries to
swallow up cruel son with his darkness
and he full counters Eskin oars physical
attack it really seems like esther osa
has the upper hand in every way his
darkness seems to have swallowed up
Eskin or son and his full counter can
repel all physical attacks both esta
rosa and zelgius think it's game over
they think Eskin or is out of options
then just when things seem hopeless a
deep cut suddenly appears across esta
roses chest Eskin or moved so fast that
Esther osa couldn't even see his attack
now I'll mostly be using one of my
favorite translations for the following
quotes because I find this one to be
especially epic Eska nor says my mighty
attacks can now reach thee and who
decided that but it doesn't stop there
oh no his cruel son completely
overpowers the darkness around it and s
Kannur says my blazing son was swallowed
up by a speck of Darkness and who
decided that
and then in what is one of the most epic
moments in all of anime s Kannur says
the one who gets to decide such things
is me we get a panel of esken or
completely dwarfing a serosa in size
showing how completely outmatched and
powerless one of the strongest
Commandments is against him then s
Kannur launches his glorious son which
is too powerful for s throws at the
handle even width is all juses help the
two strongest Commandments are powerless
to stop it what makes this an even
bigger flex as YouTube hero knucks Taku
would call it is that this wasn't even
Eska nor at his full power in fact in
the manga we are told that there's still
plenty of time before noon when s Kannur
lands the cut on esta rosa in other
words there's plenty of time before s
kannur
reaches the peak of his power and yet he
was able to embarrass Esther OSA
physically magically and rhetorically
Eskin or beat him in every way and even
zelgius couldn't do a thing to help
Esther OSA spree nunatak was too strong
for the two strongest commandments to
deal with the commandments were
presented as the strongest group and
Eska nor overpowered their two strongest
members without even using his full
power now I think you can begin to
understand why this is one of my
absolute favorite fights in the seven
deadly sins lastly I will be talking
about a manga fight that has yet to be
animated so if you want no spoilers you
can click off this video right now I'll
give you a few seconds three two one
okay now let's get to one of the most
anticipated fights ever of course I'm
talking about assault mode Mellie Otis
and the one mode Eskin or just to
quickly set up the fight for you guys
Mellie Otis had just released a sort of
limiter on his power and as a result he
seemed to have reverted to the older
more ruthless Mellie Otis Asma lascal
explained it's all over now for you
seven deadly sins and for me too Mellie
Otis is entering what even we 10
commandments feared when he was the
leader of the group annihilation mode
which is also translated as assault mode
in this way malesko suggests that this
is Mellie Otis at his strongest most
people would understandably be scared of
an uncontrollable rogue overpowered
demon Prince but not esken or esken or
jumps at the opportunity to prove that
he is the strongest sin to quote esken
or I'm in a truly good mood you know why
because this is the ideal opportunity to
prove that I pride am superior to you
wrath and just when it seems like s
Kannur has met an opponent who he cannot
beat he enters his strongest form - as
Merlyn explains his strength rises hour
by hour along with the Sun and at high
noon it reaches its peak during that
time for just one minute
he becomes the invincible incarnation of
power and it's name is the one now we
supposedly have Mellie Otis at his
strongest and Eskin or at his strongest
going at it true
a dream fight if there ever was one
Mellie Otis gives the one one thousand
divine slashes now Devine is a
meaningful word because Mellie Otis's
power is truly godlike in the world of
the seven deadly sins he reaches a
divine level of power and yet ESCA nor
seems fine after 1,000 divine slashes it
even says not but an itch not only does
he suggest that the one thousand godlike
attacks didn't hurt they didn't even
qualify as a scratch just an itch then
with just one swipe of his hand a
scanner gives Mellie Otis a wound that
takes him out of commission and Eskin or
says as a god of demons how does it feel
to be looked down upon by a human
ESCA nor has just done the impossible as
a human he not only took out a god of
demons but the opie protagonist of the
series obviously s kannur is injured and
exhausted after the fight not only
because of Mellie Otis is powerful
attacks but also because maintaining
such a powerful form takes a huge toll
on his human body in fact one punch from
Merlin at this point is enough to knock
him down however Eskin was so epic that
despite of how much accumulated pain he
must feel he acts like it's no big deal
he laughs and says he'll rough up Mellie
Otis as many times as it takes this
reminds me of that epic Zorro moment in
one piece
when he took an unimaginable amount of
damage and simply responded that nothing
happened when asked about his insane
injuries esken or no matter how much
pain he receives acts as if it's no big
deal literally right up to the point he
collapses and that's just one of the
manliest and most epic traits that an
anime character can have and that's it
for this one thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this video make
sure to smash that like button like the
epic person you are if you haven't be
sure to subscribe and this is absolutely
crucial hit that notification bell so
you actually get notified when you seven
deadly sins videos drop if you want to
take s canora's epicness with you
wherever you go you can buy the Eskin or
praise the sun and Eskin or all hail the
one shirts at anime up Broadcom
link in the description and if you like
self development in the idea becoming
the best version of yourself definitely
check out our YouTube channel project
uproar link in the description where a
friend and I talked about different ways
we improved our lives every week a big
thank you goes out to our patrons over
on patreon who help make videos like
this one possible I especially want to
thank our pro hero tier patrons the one
and only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson Kings eldress and angel
Cruz and are the one tier patrons the
ones who stand atop all clans baby ray a
17mm VP Steven and Radha a lowland
autumn Maddie Mac 239 makoto-kun and
Keylong and the patrons who transcend
greatness itself Regan Harrison and Lord
Knutson or the chosen few who have been
acknowledged by the Lord we go himself
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon.com
slash anime uproar and becoming a patron
today for as little as $1 if you do so
you'll get your name featured in future
videos alongside these epic people right
here and you'll even get access to our
private patron only discord so check out
patreon.com/crashcourse face cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]